mais d'abord les stratégies plus de
gagnantes et perdantes à travers le
monde et au canada
la propagation de lakovic 19 accélère
dans le monde
le virus ne connaît pas de frontières
une vaste expérience naturelle où des
centaines de pays de province de région
essaient chacun différentes choses pour
contenir la pendule résultats dans
certains pays des millions de personnes
ont été atteintes
alors que dans d'autres dont la chine
très peu quelques dizaines de milliers
pourquoi stratégie grave chute bête on a
parlé à une vingtaine d'experts pour
comprendre
ils ont étudié les meilleurs et les
pires stratégie et on en tirer des
leçons
et à travers le canada des experts et
l'âme à présent qu'on applique ses
leçons
la leçon la plus importante c'est que
des gouvernements de partout dans le
monde peu importe leur revenu ont réussi
à contenir la maladie
ça veut dire qu'aucun gouvernement ne
peut avoir l'excusé que c'est trop
difficile
je crois que les pays occidentaux
pensaient qu'il serait capable de gérer
cette épidémie alors je crois qu'ils ont
sous-estimé jusqu'à quel point ce virus
était difficile à contrôler le dr tim
evans
ld sous directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
même avec les avertissements des
épidémiologistes vraiment sa peau est un
désert il y avait toujours un confiance
que non ça va pas être aussi pire que ça
et je crois que c'était un peu le fait
que en chine
il avait bien contrôlé sa en janvier
2020 en chine le nombre de cas nouveaux
quatre jours
en mars l'épidémie est maîtrisé celle de
corée du sud est en voie de l'être
un contraste avec ce qu'elle est arrivée
ensuite ailleurs dans le monde comme en
italie en france au canada aux états
unis
je dirais que jusqu'à présent on n'a pas
assez a pris de l'expérience de ces pays
devant l'inconnu en janvier la chaîne a
eu recours à un confinement rapide et
sévère 50 millions de personnes 17
villes
qu'est ce qu'on avait à prendre ce pays
d'abord je crois que leur système de
soleil ont testé la population hélas
midi en février la corée du sud inquiète
la planète comme l'italie les deux pays
suivent une trajectoire semblable leur
population est de taille similaire
pourtant trois semaines plus tard leurs
situations divergent
la colère a réagi très vite à cause de
l'expérience avec me l'avait indiqué
john cho yang ho cho pulnoy la
principale différence
la voilà au 16 janvier avant même son
premier cas la corée du sud développe un
test diagnostique au 20 mars le pays
avait testé trois cent mille personnes
plus que tout autre pays à ce moment là
le pays menait sans test pour chaque cas
positifs l'italie n'atteindra ce tout
que deux mois plus tard avec 32 mille
morts et au même moment la corée du sud
en compte 234
et c'était non seulement la diagnostique
c'était tout le système d'information
qu'il faut et aussi la mobilisation des
travailleurs pour le contact réel
l'idée c'est de tester tracé isolé
pour chacun affectés on remonte la
chaîne de contacter rapidement grâce à
des équipes d'enquêteurs ou des
applications
il identifie les lieux fréquentés par
les personnes affectées tests tous les
contacts
il remonte la piste pour isoler
stratégiquement d'autres ont misé sur
cette approche le vietnam taiwan la
thaïlande le japon en contrôlant tôt
l'épidémie avec les tests et le traçage
plusieurs ont évité un parti ou
complètement l'imposition de confinement
des pays comme le vietnam ou le sénégal
on aurait cru qu'il n'en n'auraient pas
les moyens mais ils ont déployé les
tests et le traçage de manière très
efficace grâce à d'excellents services
de santé communautaire thomas et son
équipe à l'université d'oxford
royaume-uni compile et analyse les
mesures prises par chaque pays
mayol dans le monde et dans beaucoup de
pays européens
on a moins vu cette capacité d'employer
ce type de test et de traçage pour
contenir la maladie pour plusieurs
chercheurs c'est l'échec d'une mesure
élémentaire de santé publique
je crois que l'une des choses là plus
important c'est qu'il y avait une
sous-estimation de la transmission est
symptomatique
nous serons en capacité de tester toute
personne présentant des symptômes
en occident on teste presque
exclusivement les personnes présentant
des symptômes
c'était aussi le fait que quand il
voulait changer le comportement de leurs
systèmes de testing ils ont vu que
c'était très très difficile
c'était des ressources au niveau de la
santé publique qui n'ont pas une
capacité mobiliser très facile souvent
ces deux départements qui ont qui n'ont
pas beaucoup de personnes et c'était un
système qui n'étaient pas capables
d'engager dix fois plus le nombre de
personnes
en avril au palmarès des pays les plus
touchés par la colline on retrouve
certains des pays les plus riches du
monde
notre au canada aux états unis et en
europe
je crois que plus tôt la réaction
c'était on va voir qu'est ce qui se
passe on entre on a perdu ce temps au
moment où on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait un problème il était trop tard
pour contenir la maladie avec les tests
et le traçage février et mars
les pays prenait des décisions dans une
extrême incertitudes les gouvernements
décident est presque aveugle sous les
rassemblements sont interdits les pays
occidentaux recours alors à des mesures
extrêmes
l' oms a déclaré l'état de pandémie
plein de pays ont commencé à fermer à
imposer des mesures sévères de
confinement même si à certains endroits
la maladie n'avait même pas commencé à
se propager ce qu'on a vu c'est que
plusieurs gouvernements que pierre les
uns sur les autres sans vraiment suivre
les recommandations des corps
scientifique pour chaque pays
thomaes elle a compilé les mesures
adoptées il a créé un index de sévérité
que les mesures sont sévères
plus l'index est élevé avant l'annoncé
de l'om est peu de mesures sont en place
en dehors de l'asie en deux semaines peu
importe l'état de l'éclosion locale les
pays ont mis en place des mesures de
confinement semblables nous avons
utilisé des confinement pour ce genre de
situation c'est comme utiliser une
amputation pour traiter un membre
infecté il faut le faire si c'est
nécessaire mais c'est un choix qui coûte
très cher des experts rappellent alors
le b à ba du contrôle d'une épidémie
comme un job un spécialiste en maladies
infectieuses
que ce soit pour une école ou un pays
tous vos efforts doivent être dirigés
pour empêcher la maladie de rentrer en
contrôlant les frontières très tôt comme
l'ont fait les pays asiatiques mais
aussi l'australie la nouvelle-zélande la
meilleure réaction initiale est de
garder la maladie à l'extérieur du pays
mais si vous n'y arrivez pas parce que
c'est impossible de le faire
la prochaine étape est un excellent
système de test et de traçage le but
confiné seulement les malades avant la
propagation exponentielle du virus
en cas de perte de contrôle l'ultime
recours est alors de confier tout le
monde à mon avis les confinements sont
toujours un aveu d'échec de tous les
autres efforts alors que l'europe puis
l'amérique entre en confinement un
nouveau mantra fait son apparition
cette stratégie découle en partie d'une
étude publiée par l'université d'oxford
qui montre la démographe simon à minami
étudie les effets de l'aco vide au
canada et en europe toutes les
stratégies les pandémies des hommes ont
découlé de cette approche
l'aplatissement de la courbe était une
réponse rationnelle à ce que nous avions
observé à one à bergame et à new york
et pour écraser la courbe te masser
l'attenté de trouver les mesures les
plus efficaces
mais il découvre que la leçon la plus
importante de toutes et qu'il faut agir
rapidement
au printemps une grande partie de la
différence entre les résultats des pays
ne s'explique pas par le type de mesures
imposées mais par la vitesse à laquelle
elles ont été appliquées
on peut répartir les pays en quatre
types de réponses d'abord ceux qui ont
agi vite et fermement avec des mesures
mises en place en moins de trente cinq
jours après le premier cas comme
l'australie et la nouvelle-zélande
ensuite ceux qui ont agi vite mais avec
des mesures moins sévère ils ont connu
plus de décès en moyenne comme la
turquie puis ceux qui ont sévèrement
confiné mais tu as comme le royaume-uni
la france et l'italie
enfin ce avec le plus de décès ceux qui
ont été lents avec des mesures moins
sévère comme le brésil l'iran et le
canada maîtriser rapidement l'épidémie a
aussi un autre effet capitale sur la
confiance de la population
les gouvernements qui n'ont pas agi de
manière décisive dans les premiers mois
ont vu leur population perdre confiance
dans l'efficacité des mesures
recommandées et donc moins se conformer
aux nouvelles mesures imposées par la
suite
parmi les pays les plus frappés par
l'aco vide les etats-unis mais aussi le
brésil le royaume-uni la russie des pays
qui ont aussi en commun d'avoir à leur
tête des leaders qui ont nié la gravité
du virus
[Musique]
simon baker dirige l'étude haïti est une
étude internationale qui vise à
comprendre qu'ils adhèrent mieux aux
mesures sanitaires et pourquoi il a
sondé 20000 personnes de plus de 140
pays les pays dans lesquels la
population a le moins adhérer aux gestes
barrière se sont les pays où il ya eu le
plus de doutes sur la sévérité des
mesures imposées et le moins de
confiance envers le gouvernement
les actions prises dès le début ont été
décisives sur la trajectoire que les
différents pays allait ensuite emprunté
en rétrospective
un an plus tard certains catégorise les
stratégies nationales en deux types d'
approche l'asie comme l'australie et la
nouvelle-zélande ont adopté des
politiques d éradication du virus par
contre les pires au pl canada les etats
unis se n'a pas adopté des politiques de
mitigation de la transmission du vih
l'objectif a été toujours 2c rendra au
niveau suffisamment faible de
transmission du virus
pour pouvoir vivre avec le virus très
différent des l'éradication
les pays qui ont agi avec fermeté pour
éradiquer le virus quant à présent très
peu de nouveaux cas ceux qui ont mitigé
le virus seulement assez pour préserver
leurs systèmes hospitaliers ont pour la
plupart vu le nombre de cas atteindre de
nouveaux sommets comme au canada
au canada depuis des mois les provinces
tangue entre ouvertures vont réouvrir
certaines activités confinement partiel
boys et confinement total pour quatre
semaines
on va avoir un couvre-feu est ce que
nous avons réussi à faire céder tirer ça
pendant deux périodes démesurée avec un
schéma flou de confinement et de
déconfinement et ça se traduit par
beaucoup de frustration et d'inquiétude
dans la population
je ne sais même plus ce que signifie
confinement techniquement toronto est
confiné où les rues sont bondées les cas
augmentent
bref on retient l'épidémie on ne
contrôle pas on nageait repas tout ce
qu'on fait c'est tenir
comment sommes nous arrivés là et
comment faire mieux
premier cas présumés de coronavirus
chinois étaient identifiés au canada fin
janvier 2020 les premiers cas canadiens
sont détectés aux portes d'entrée du
pays dans les villes où on voyage le
plus toronto vancouver montréal
on regarde aussi par rapport aux
origines des vols et au déplacement pour
voir s il ya d'autres étapes à prendre
le docteur joyce à toronto et d'autres
scientifiques exhorte le gouvernement de
fermer les frontières
la réponse du canada a été fortement
teintée par la croyance entretenu dans
certains cercles que la fermeture des
frontières serait plus nuisible que
bénéfique
un message martelé pendant des semaines
aussi entretenu par l'organisation
mondiale la santé nih mars
ces pays avaient fermé leurs frontières
aux voyages non essentiels
cela avait interdit les voyages en
provenance des pays à risque et cela
impose et une quarantaine obligatoire au
canada rien de ça
au vietnam en thaïlande par exemple
toutes personnes qui entraient au pays
étaient dès son arrivée mise en
quarantaine forcée
au canada on n'avait rien de ça ce
retard à contrôler les frontières à lui
seul a déclenché une cascade de défis
beaucoup plus vaste qu'on a ensuite vécu
au canada
les restrictions de voyage annoncé
aujourd'hui le 16 mars le gouvernement
canadien annonce la fermeture des
frontières
le québec a eu sa semaine de relâche en
premier il n'y avait alors aucun
avertissement aux voyageurs
l'ontario l'a eu en deuxième le fédéral
a émis des avertissements mais d'oxford
nous a dit voyager alors certains l'ont
fait la colombie britannique l'a eu en
troisième et on leur a dit de ne pas
voyager
résultat au québec en mars voici les cas
importés par des voyageurs
en tout plus de 1500 en ontario environ
en colombie britannique c'est moins de
300 ces cas sont le point de départ de
l'épidémie au pays le canada n'est alors
pas prêt à tester en grand nombre
n'avions pas de système de test en place
au printemps on en n'avait pas la
capacité
une façon de savoir si on est assez et
de regarder le pourcentage de tests
positifs un pourcentage supérieur à 5%
indique que le nombre de tests et sans
doute insuffisant et que de nombreux cas
ne sont pas dépistés pendant la majeure
partie de la première vague
le canada est bien au-dessus de 5%
c'est bien moins que la corée du sud
mais mieux que les états unis une
province fait exception l'alberta où on
fait du dépistage préventif
[Musique]
l'alberta choisi de ne pas prendre de
mesures restrictives mais plutôt
d'intensifier les tests dans un sens ils
ont suivi le mode de la corée du sud et
c'est ce qui leur a permis de bien
traverser la première lac pendant les
quatre provinces de l'atlantique s'isole
du reste du pays elles ferment leurs
frontières et forment la bulle de
l'atlantique les provinces de
l'atlantique ne sont pas seulement le
modèle pour le pays mais aussi au modèle
international de réussite ils ont limité
les déplacements
ils ont fait des tests eurent fait du
traçage et ont mis en place des mesures
au bon moment ils ont très bien fait au
canada lors de la première vague
la majorité des décès ont eu lieu au
québec et en ontario
la colombie britannique a été épargnée
avec à peine cent soixante dix sept
décès 80 % de ces décès ont eu lieu dans
des résidences et centres de soins pour
personnes âgées
la situation s'est beaucoup détériorée
dans les semaines et les femmes d'allah
à étudier pourquoi la colombie
britannique s'en est mieux sorti il
observe des différences financières et
structurelles qui précède la co vide
mais ce n'est pas tout en colombie
britannique
ils ont recommandé plus rapidement le
port du masque dans les foyers de soins
de longue durée
très vite ils ont recommandé que le
personnel travaille exclusivement dans
un seul foyer
ils ont été plus rapides à envoyer des
équipes de prévention des infections en
ontario et au québec en particulier ces
mêmes mesures ont été mises en place que
plusieurs semaines plus tard la colombie
britannique semble avoir eu une très
bonne maîtrise de la situation et une de
leurs forces a été de fournir des
informations claires des données boni
yayi étaient très bonnes pour présenter
des statistiques et des projections et
un plan de ce qui se passait au québec
c'est exactement le contraire
personne ne vous présentez des scénarios
les personnes qui veut jouer pour la
dame lemay à l'astrologie parce que ça
devient dans cet ordre au québec pendant
longtemps le gouvernement refuse de
présenter ses projections bouddha
lorsqu'on lui a demandé de voir les
donner sa réponse a été c'est trop
complexe
vous ne comprendrez pas si vous traitez
les gens comme des idiots ils agiront
comme des idiots
[Musique]
à l'été à travers le pays les
confinements ont aplati la cua
on recense moins de 300 cas par jour si
vous êtes au gouvernement en mai juin
vous pensez que vous vous êtes plutôt
bien débrouillé il n'y a pas eu de
scénarios comme à new york il n'y a pas
eu de bergame
il n'y a pas eu de one vous vous dites
waouh on s'en est bien sorti est-ce que
la seconde vague aurait pu être évité
oui on a raté notre charge
pour plusieurs experts c'était
l'occasion de mettre en place une
structure de test et de traçage efficace
et de reprendre contrôle de la situation
pour éviter un nouveau confinement
tout le monde était au courant et leçons
à tirer
après la première vague au mois de juin
juillet août
les préparations pour la deuxième vague
je crois que on a perdu trois mois très
important
en automne la seconde vague déferle sur
canada co le ministre de la santé
notariaux au moins de septembre malik
oui on va engager 500 personnes pour
faire le contact ricine je me suis dit
mais il aurait dû engager ces gens mais
non seulement cinq cent sept mille
personnes au mois de juin
conséquence plusieurs provinces n'ont
pas le choix elle doit se refermer
mais avec des compromis
ashley tweet siège à la table
scientifique qui conseille le
gouvernement ontarien qu'on a alors
c'est une sorte de confinement modifier
ou nous fermons stratégiquement des
sites ou des entreprises et nos gardes
ont ouvert des écoles en priorisant
quelque sorte ce qu'on veut garder
ouvert le but à baisser le nombre de cas
juste assez pour protéger les hôpitaux
mais sans plus une approche de
mitigation garder nos enfants dans les
écoles
chaque province trouve alors son propre
équilibre entre économie et santé voici
l'évolution de l'index de ces vérités
d'oxford appliquée aux provinces
canadiennes
ici les provinces de l'atlantique qui
malgré leur nombre de cas faibles ont
maintenu pendant longtemps des mesures
sévères
pendant ce temps l'alberta et la
saskatchewan tarder à resserrer leurs
mesures sanitaires
un délai qui contribuera à une forte
croissance des cas à l'automne je pense
que la perception du manitoba de la
saskatchewan et de l'alberta était on
gère l'économie d'abord la maladie
ensuite ils ont tous réagi très tard les
gouvernements tentent de préserver des
secteurs économiques tout en demandant à
la population de respecter les gestes
barrière tout le monde doit réduire ses
comptes 1 j'ai besoin d'un grand effort
collectif
mais c'est insuffisant en novembre en
dehors de la bulle de l'atlantique
presque partout au pays l'écart grimpe
en flèche au début de la deuxième vague
ce qui faisait grimper le nombre de cas
cités et les écoles puis les usines
depuis peu sa changer ce qui est devenu
un problème ce sont les commerces
c'est donc une crise qui relève de la
politique et qui dépassent les
comportements individuels
al'approche du temps des fêtes la
fatigue se fait sentir
les gouvernements seront peu à peu à
l'évidence imposant des mesures de plus
en plus sévère si vous demandez à
n'importe quel québécoise qu'il faut
faire pour sortir du confinement
pas un seul ne pourrait répondre à cette
question parce qu'on ne nous a jamais
présenté des données
personne ne travaille en fonction d'un
objectif final l'australie a une
stratégie qui détaille ce qu'il faut
précisément pour entrer et sortir d'un
confinement
tout le monde sait quel nombre de cas
par jour va déclencher une réaction
selon plusieurs experts
à la manière de l'australie une
politique nationale unique avec des
balises claires à l'échelle du pays est
indispensable si en mai ou juin nous
nous étions mis d'accord sur une réponse
nationale sur une stratégie pour
contrôler la coved nous serions bien
plus
andrew morris a démarré en novembre un
mot clic coville 0 d'autres parlent de
bouclier canadien
un mouvement qui prend de l'ampleur
endossé par des dizaines d'autres
experts canadiens
ils réclament que le canada adopte une
approche d'éradication
cette idée est venue en observant les
pays qui ont échoué et ceux qui ont
réussi
l'idée derrière kobe 2 0 c'est de se
dire pourquoi ne pas viser mieux que
d'avancer à tâtons le plan pour s'en
sortir
d'abord imposé un contrôle serré des
frontières ensuite maintenir
déconfinement ferme jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y
ait plus de cas ou presque les plus
important c'est de ne pas accepter un
nombre de cas moyens après cette vague
parce que si vous ne réduisez pas assez
ce nombre de cas et finit toujours par
remonter
enfin pendant ce temps mettre en place
un système efficace et rapide de test et
de traçage avec un nombre faible de
degas devient alors possible de
conquérir toute éclosion futur est ainsi
cessé pour de bon les confinements
prolongée à mon avis le pire scénario
c'est d'être sur une montagne russe avec
déconfinement périodiques parce que vous
n'aplatisse est jamais assez la courbe
est donc vous tuer l'économie plusieurs
fois sans tirer profit des bénéfices
pour la santé publique
personne ne nous offre le choix entre
ces options le gouvernement fait des
choix pour nous en ce moment et ne nous
présente aucune autre option
ça doit être une discussion plus large
que nous devons avoir en société au
canada comme dans bien des pays
les confinements ces tirs certains pays
entre dans une troisième vague ailleurs
en contrastant nouvel élan en australie
en chine
la vie a repris des airs
avant la pandémie
les éclosions occasionnels sont
immédiatement contrôler le pays dont
l'économie augmentent le plus cette
année et la chine on présente souvent
des arguments économiques pour contester
les mesures de contrôle mais c'est une
vision à court terme et dans les
derniers mois à mon avis ces arguments
se sont évaporés est le seul moyen de
minimiser les effets de la maladie sur
l'économie et la société
c'est de minimiser la maladie elle-même